When you're angry or do something impulsive, that's your reptilian brain in action, right? And if you talk yourself out of that impulsive act or gain control over your wrath, that's your neocortex at work, isn't it? And those emotions you feel, such as grief when a loved one dies, or joy at the birth of a child. Those are just things that happen to you in reaction to events in your life, correct? And they're universal across cultures, aren't they? Well, maybe not. What if emotions are things that our brain constructs to make sense of the signals it gets from our body
当你感到愤怒或做出冲动的事情时，那是你的爬行动物脑在起作用，对吧？如果你说服自己放弃那种冲动行为或者控制住你的怒火，那就是你的新皮层在发挥作用，不是吗？还有你感受到的那些情绪，比如挚爱离世时的悲伤，或者孩子出生时的喜悦。这些只是你在对生活中的事件做出反应时发生在你身上的事情，对吗？而且它们在各种文化中都是普遍存在的，不是吗？嗯，也许并非如此。如果情绪是大脑为了理解它从我们身体获得的信号而构建的东西呢？
and from the world around us? What if the way you think about your brain and how and why it functions is just plain wrong? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
以及从我们周围的世界获得的信号？如果你对大脑的看法、它的运作方式和原因完全是错误的，又会怎样？欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，专门探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
Our guest today is Dr. Lisa Feldman-Barratt, a distinguished professor of psychology at Northeastern University. Dr. Barrett has spent more than three decades studying emotion. Her research has helped to develop the idea that the human brain creates emotions by predicting rather than reacting to what happens in the world around us. She's published more than 240 scientific papers and is also a prolific science communicator writing articles and books about brain science for the general public.
我们今天的嘉宾是东北大学（Northeastern University）心理学杰出教授丽莎·费尔德曼·巴雷特（Dr. Lisa Feldman-Barratt）博士。巴雷特博士花了三十多年的时间研究情绪。她的研究帮助形成了一种观点，即人脑是通过预测而不是对我们周围发生的事情做出反应来创造情绪的。她已经发表了240多篇科学论文，同时也是一位多产的科学传播者，为公众撰写了大量关于大脑科学的文章和书籍。
Her two most recent books are how emotions are made, published in 2017, and seven and a half lessons about the brain, which came out in November. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Barrett. Oh, it's a pleasure to be here, Kim. I want to start with an idea that opens your new book, which is that the main purpose of the brain is not to think, but to regulate our bodies. This may seem counterintuitive or come as a surprise to some of our listeners.
她最近的两本书是2017年出版的《情绪是如何产生的》（How Emotions Are Made），以及11月出版的《关于大脑的七个半堂课》（Seven and a Half Lessons About the Brain）。非常感谢您今天能作客我们的节目，巴雷特博士。哦，很高兴能来到这里，金。我想从你新书开头的一个观点开始，那就是大脑的主要目的不是思考，而是调节我们的身体。这听觉上可能有点违背直觉，或者会让听众感到惊讶。
I'm wondering, can you explain how you came to this conclusion and why it's so important? I actually started with the question of why do we even have a brain? That blob of meat between your ears is the most expensive organ that you have in your whole body. And so why do we even have a brain? And so what I did was I went back in the literature, and I looked in the literature on evolutionary neuroscience to a time when animals on the earth didn't have brains and looked at the evolution of the brain and found some really remarkable evidence that brains evolved
我想知道，你能解释一下你是如何得出这个结论的吗？为什么它如此重要？我其实是从“我们为什么要有大脑”这个问题开始的。你两耳之间那团肉是你全身最昂贵的器官。那么我们为什么还要有大脑呢？所以我做的是，我查阅了文献，查阅了进化神经科学的文献，回溯到地球上的动物还没有大脑的时期，研究了大脑的进化，并发现了一些非常显著的证据，表明大脑的进化
under the selection pressure of predation. So during the Cambrian period, animals learned to hunt one another deliberately and eat each other. And it's not that animals didn't eat each other before then, but there was very little evidence of actual hunting. And so under the pressure, selection pressure of hunting, what happened is that bodies got bigger and required much more coordination of internal bodily systems because animals without brains are don't have very much going on inside they have some some internal coordination but not very much and they really have no sophisticated senses to speak of that is they don't see they don't hear they don't smell they really don't know very much about the world outside their own bodies and what you see under predation is that
是在捕食的选择压力下发生的。所以在寒武纪时期，动物学会了刻意地互相猎杀并吃掉对方。并不是说在此之前动物不吃对方，但几乎没有实际猎杀的证据。因此，在捕食的选择压力下，发生的情况是身体变大了，需要对内部身体系统进行更多的协调，因为没有大脑的动物体内没有发生太多事情，它们有一些内部协调但非常少，而且它们真的没有说得出口的高级感官，也就是说它们看不见、听不见、闻不到，它们对自身身体之外的世界真的了解不多，而你在捕食现象中看到的是
bodies get bigger, senses evolve, and brains appear. And if you look at the anatomy of the brain, what you see is that at the core of the brain, even at the core of the cortex, cerebral cortex, are the regions that are regulating the systems of your body, your immune system, your metabolism, an endocrine system, your autonomic nervous system, and your skeletal muscle system. And the networks in the brain that are responsible for remembering and thinking and seeing even are actually involved in regulating the body. And so the bottom line is that we do think and we do feel and we do see, but we do those things in the service of regulating the systems of the body.
身体变大，感官进化，大脑出现。如果你观察大脑的解剖结构，你会发现大脑的核心，甚至是 cerebral cortex（大脑皮层）的核心，都是那些调节你身体系统的区域，你的免疫系统、新陈代谢、内分泌系统、自主神经系统和骨骼肌肉系统。大脑中负责记忆、思考甚至视觉的网络实际上也参与了调节身体。所以底线是，我们确实会思考，我们确实有感觉，我们也确实能看见，但我们做这些事情是为了服务于调节身体系统。
Now, we don't experience every feeling of gratitude or sadness. every hug we give, every insult we bear as having anything to do with the body, but it does. And the reason why this is important is that many of the things that we think of as mental, like illnesses like depression and anxiety, or even just, you know, things like seeing or thinking, actually have important aspects to them that are related to the body. So depression, for example, in addition to being a mental illness and having immune, you know, functioning problems is also a metabolic illness, actually. And that's why it's important that we understand. It really starts to break down the boundary between the mental and the physical. And so, you know, we can understand, for example, that all mental disorders actually have basic physical processes that are in disarray.
现在，我们并没有把每一次感受到的感激或悲伤、每一个拥抱、每一次忍受的侮辱都体验为与身体有任何关系，但其实是有的。为什么这一点很重要呢？因为许多我们认为是精神上的事情，比如像抑郁和焦虑这样的疾病，甚至只是像看东西或思考这样简单的事情，其实都有与身体相关的重要方面。以抑郁症为例，除了是一种精神疾病并存在免疫功能问题之外，它其实也是一种代谢性疾病。这就是为什么理解这一点很重要。它确实开始打破精神与身体之间的界限。所以，我们可以理解，例如，所有精神失调实际上都有处于紊乱状态的基本生理过程；
and also things we think of as mental, physical illnesses like cardiovascular disease and so one, actually have mental aspects to them, which are really important to understand. So a few moments ago you talked about the brain being the most expensive organ. What do you mean by that? Metabolically speaking, your brain costs you 20% of your metabolic budget. That's more than your heart. That's more than your lungs. That's more than your liver. it's a very expensive organ to keep running. All those little neurons and so on. It's really expensive, actually, metabolically speaking. And it turns out that metabolic efficiency is a major selection pressure, not just on any species that's alive. It's true that it also, you know, it's important for the evolution of any species. It's also important for your health, mental and physical. If you have
并且我们也认为属于精神或生理疾病的疾病，如心血管疾病等等，实际上也有它们的精神层面，这是非常需要去理解的。所以刚才你谈到大脑是最昂贵的器官。你是什么意思？从代谢的角度来说，你的大脑消耗了你20%的代谢预算。这比你的心脏还要多。比你的肺还要多。比你的肝脏还要多。要维持它的运转，这是一个非常昂贵的器官。所有那些小神经元等等。从代谢的角度来看，实际上非常昂贵。事实证明，代谢效率是一个主要的压力选择，不仅对任何活着的物种是这样。确实它也，你知道的，对任何物种的进化都很重要。它对你的健康，无论是心理还是生理健康，也同样重要。如果你有
metabolic dysregulation or things are not running as efficiently metabolically. I'm not just talking about circulating glucose or something. That's like one very small part of a very large, complicated system. If your energy regulation is not proceeding in a metabolically efficient way, you will get sick. And are our brains more expensive than other mammalian brains? I mean, we have this big, big hunk of meat up there. Yes, they are. Yes. You know, when you look at primates, let's say relative to other mammals, primates do have bigger brains relative to their body size than other mammals do, and humans have bigger brains. But I would say that, you know, the size of the cerebral cortex is not any bigger than you would expect for a primate who has a brain of our size.
代谢失调或者代谢运转效率不高。我指的不仅仅是循环中的葡萄糖之类的东西。那就像是一个非常庞大、复杂系统中的一小部分。如果你的能量调节不是以代谢高效的方式进行，你就会生病。我们的哺乳动物大脑比其他哺乳动物的大脑更贵吗？我的意思是，我们在上面有这么大一块肉。是的，它们是。是的。你知道，当你观察灵长类动物时，比如说与其他哺乳动物相比，与其他哺乳动物相比，灵长类动物相对于它们的体型确实有更大的大脑，人类的大脑也更大。但我要说的是，你知道，大脑皮层的大小并不比你对一个拥有我们这样大小大脑的灵长类动物的预期要大。
So it's not like our cerebral cortex is so big relative to the rest of our brain. It's just we have a big brain relative to our body size and our cerebral cortex is as big as you might expect for a creature who has a brain of our size. But there is some genetic upregulation in the human brain that makes it more expensive to run, particularly in the cerebral cortex, in particular layers of the cerebral cortex that have to do with our ability to, I guess you could say, compress information, summarize information from multiple sources so that we can do things like abstraction. Another, what might be a surprising point to some people in your book, I think I alluded to it a little bit in the introduction, is the way that many of us were taught about the brain is
所以并不是说我们的大脑皮层相对于我们大脑的其他部分那么大。只是相对于我们的体型而言，我们有一个很大的大脑，而我们的大脑皮层的大小正如你对一个拥有我们这样大小大脑的生物所期望的那样。但人类大脑中确实有一些基因上调，使其运转成本更高，特别是在大脑皮层中，在与我们的能力有关的大脑皮层的特定层中，我想你可以说，是压缩信息，总结来自多个来源的信息，以便我们能够做抽象之类的事情。另一个对某些人来说可能很出乎意料的观点，在你的书中，我想我在引言中稍微提到了这一点，就是我们很多人被灌输的关于大脑的知识是
wrong. So a lot of our listeners, I'm sure remember learning that they're three, Three parts to the human brain, you've been asked this a million times. We think there's the lizard or reptilian brain that controls our basic bodily functions. There's the emotional brain. And then there's the rational brain, the neocortex that's like the pinnacle of evolution and makes us supposedly superior to other animals. But you say this is incorrect. So where did the idea of a triune brain come from and how do we know that it's wrong?
错误的。所以我们的很多听众肯定都记得学过人类大脑有三个部分，这个问题你已经被问过无数次了。我们认为有控制我们基本身体功能的蜥蜴脑或爬行动物脑。然后是情绪脑。接着是理性脑，即新皮层，它就像是进化的巅峰，据称使我们在其他动物面前具有优越性。但你说这是不正确的。那么三位一体大脑（triune brain）的概念是从哪里来的，我们又是怎么知道它是错的呢？
Okay. So I got to say, I'm happy to talk about it. I have been asked about this a lot, but I'm so happy to talk about. about it because it's like one of the most pervasive myth, modern myths in science. It's not even wrong is what I would say, Kim. And I also have to say that this is not my research, right? Like this is, I don't do research on this topic, although I do research on brain organization and its relevance for psychological functioning. And I do research on the structure and function of tissue that is called limbic, but it's not called limbic because it's about a motion. It's really more
好的。所以我要说，我很高兴谈论这个。这个问题我已经被问过很多次了，但我非常高兴谈论它，因为这是科学中最普遍的神话之一，现代神话之一。金，我甚至可以说它根本不是真的。我必须说，这不是我的研究，对吧？就像这个，我不做这个课题的研究，尽管我确实研究大脑组织及其与心理功能的关系。我确实研究被称为边缘系统（limbic）的组织的结构和功能，但它被称为边缘系统不是因为它与情绪有关，它其实更多地
about the anatomical structure of the tissue. But let me just say that the idea of a triune brain, a brain in three layers, really can be, I've traced it all the way back to Plato. Wow. Because, you know, Plato talked about the soul or the psyche, which is not exactly the same as a mind, but for present purposes, it's like close enough. He talked about the psyche as having the human psyche is having three parts, one part for instinct, one part for emotion, which he represented as two beasts, right, two horses, and then a charioteer, which is human rationality, which obviously controls the beast. And so right there, you have this idea of an inner beast and a rational part, and they're in constant battle for control of the chariot,
与组织的解剖结构有关。但让我直说吧，三位一体大脑的概念，即三层大脑的观点，真的可以追溯到柏拉图。哇。因为，你知道，柏拉图谈到了灵魂或心灵（psyche），这不完全等同于mind（心智），但为了目前的讨论目的，这就足够接近了。他谈到心灵时说人类的心灵有三个部分，一部分用于本能，一部分用于情绪，他将其表现为两头野兽，对吧，两匹马，然后是一个御者，也就是人类的理性，它显然控制着野兽。所以就在那里，你有了一个内在野兽和理性的概念，它们在不断争夺战车的控制权，
of your behavior. That's basically the idea. And so, You know, fast forward like a couple of thousand years and, you know, we're in the era of modern neuroscience like in the, you know, mid-20th century. And you have scientists who are using the best tools available to them, which is, you know, the naked eye or maybe some not so powerful microscopes with some dyes. And, you know, you look at a lizard brain and a lizard brain looks like it has a set of parts. And then you look at an early, like a small mammal brain, like a rat. And you all look there to look like there are some extra parts there.
也就是你的行为。这基本上就是这个概念。所以，你知道，快进几千年，然后，我们在现代神经科学的时代，比如在20世纪中叶。你有一些科学家在使用他们能获得的最好工具，也就是，你知道的，肉眼，或者也许是一些带有染料的、不太强大的显微镜。而且，你知道，你观察蜥蜴脑，蜥蜴脑看起来像有一组部件。然后你观察一个早期的、类似小哺乳动物的大脑，比如老鼠。你也会觉得那里好像有一些额外的部件。
And then you look at a human. You're like, oh, wow, there's really definitely a really big extra part there. And so the idea that really grew out of this that comes from Paul McLean, who was a neuroscientist, in Boston, actually, where I live in the 1940s, is this idea that lizards have circuitry for instincts. And then layered on top of that evolved the limbic system, limbic meaning border, which is really old cortex, considered to be old cortex, that borders these lizard parts, which is where emotions live.
然后你观察人类。你会想，哦，哇，那里绝对有一个非常大的额外部件。因此，这个观点实际上是由波士顿的神经科学家保罗·麦克林（Paul MacLean）提出的——顺便说一句，我就住在波士顿——他在20世纪40年代提出了这个观点，即蜥蜴具有本能的神经回路。然后在它之上叠加进化出了边缘系统（limbic system），limbic意为边界，这被认为是古老的皮层，位于这些蜥蜴部件的边缘，也就是情绪居住的地方。
And then layered on top of that is the new part of the cortex, the neocortex, which is where rationality lives, the pinnacle, as you say, of evolution. And so there are a couple of things wrong with this view. One is that evolution, we aren't the pinnacle of anything. Evolution didn't aim itself at us to use paraphrase wording from Henry Gee, the paleontologist, Henry Gee. And, you know, animals are well adapted to their niche. If they still, if a species still is around, you know, after a couple of, 100,000 years, or longer, then it means it's well adapted to its niche. And, you know,
然后在此之上叠加的是皮层的新部分，即新皮层，这是理性居住的地方，正如你所说，是进化的巅峰。所以这个观点有几个错误之处。一个是，进化，我们不是任何事物的巅峰。用古生物学家亨利·吉（Henry Gee）的话来改写，进化并没有把目标对准我们。而且，你知道，动物对它们的生态位适应得很好。如果它们仍然，如果一个物种在几千、10万年或更长时间后依然存在，那就意味着它对自己的生态位适应得很好。而且，老实说，
other animals have some pretty miraculous abilities to do things that we don't have, frankly, and that we endow our superheroes with. So, yes, it's true. We can do some pretty amazing things as humans, but other animals can do very amazing things like grow back limbs. Yeah, we can't fly. We can't grow back limbs. We definitely can't grow new neurons in most of our brains. Whereas other animals, there are animals who can do all of those things, or each of those things, right? But more importantly, the evidence for molecular genetics, when you peer in deep into the cells, the molecular structure of cells, and you look at the genes deep within what you see really clear evidence that brains did not evolve like sedimentary rock, you know, or what I think of it is, you know, you've got this like deep animal beast, like inner ancient beast. And then, you know, what evolved on top of that was, you know, rationality like, like icing. on an already baked cake, you know? Brains didn't evolve that way.
其他动物有一些非常奇妙的能力，可以做我们做不到的事情，而我们将这些能力赋予了我们的超级英雄。所以，是的，这是真的，作为人类，我们可以做一些非常惊人的事情，但其他动物可以做非常惊人的事情，比如肢体再生。是的，我们不会飞。我们不能肢体再生。我们绝对不能在我们大部分大脑中培育新的神经元。而其他动物，有些动物可以做所有这些事情，或者每种事情，对吧？但更重要的是，来自分子遗传学的证据，当你深入细胞内部，观察细胞的分子结构，并观察深层的基因时，你会发现非常清晰的证据，表明大脑并不是像沉积岩那样进化的，你知道的，或者正如我想象的那样，你拥有这种深层的动物野兽般的内在远古野兽。然后，你知道，在它之上进化出来的是理性，就像是在
They just didn't. That's the evidence. And the evidence has been around for more than 50 years and yet hasn't managed to percolate its way into, not just into the public sphere, but into psychology textbooks. Like, yeah, anytime you read that the amygdala and other parts of the limbic system, which I would put in scare quotes, because there's, There is no limbic system in your brain. Anytime, you know, you read that the amygdala or the limbic system is being regulated by the prefrontal cortex, that is a phrasing which rests on this old, really mistaken idea that, you know, you have this inner beast lurking inside your brain, which is constantly.
已经烤好的蛋糕上的糖霜，你知道吗？大脑不是那样进化的。它们就是没有。这就是证据。这些证据已经存在了50多年，然而它却未能渗透到公众视野中，甚至没有渗透到心理学教科书中。就像，是的，任何时候你读到杏仁核和边缘系统的其他部分（我会在边缘系统加上引号，因为你的大脑中根本没有边缘系统），任何时候，你知道，你读到杏仁核或边缘系统正被前额叶皮层调节，这种说法是建立在一个陈旧的、极其错误的观点之上的，即你的大脑里潜伏着一头内在的野兽，它在不断地
in battle with your more sensible rational self and that the outcome of your you know that you're when your rational side wins you're healthy and moral and when your uh inner beast wins you're either uh you know if your inner beast wins because um you didn't try hard enough then you're not moral and uh if your inner beast wins because you um you know there's something wrong then you're sick that's just a that's just a it's a morality tale, but it doesn't reflect actually the biology of how we got these miraculous brains to begin with. You make another really interesting point in your new book that I think is another myth-busting point.
与你更明智、理性的自我进行斗争，而斗争的结果是——当你理性的一面获胜时，你是健康和道德的；而当你的内在野兽获胜时，你要么是因为……你知道的，如果你的内在野兽获胜是因为你没有足够努力，那么你就是不道德的；如果你的内在野兽获胜是因为你……你知道的，有什么地方不对劲，那么你就是生病了。这只是一则道德故事，但它并不能真正反映我们如何拥有这些神奇大脑的生物学原理。你在新书中提出了另一个非常有趣的观点，我认为这也是一个打破神话的观点。
I think a lot of people have the sense that parts of our brains kind of go dormant from time to time, and we're not using them. And I think what you're saying is neurons are firing all the time. Maybe you can explain a little bit about how that works and why. So if you look back in the history of how neurons were discovered and how they were studied, like in the 1950s, for example, one way to study the properties of a neuron was to take a big squid neuron, like literally take it out of the brain and lay it out on a table. And when you lay out a single neuron on a table that you can see, because these are like really giant squids have.
我想很多人都觉得我们大脑的某些部分有时会进入休眠状态，而我们并没有使用它们。我想你的意思是神经元一直在放电。也许你可以稍微解释一下它是如何运作的，以及为什么会这样。因此，如果你回顾神经元是如何被发现以及它们是如何被研究的历史，比如在20世纪50年代，研究神经元属性的一种方法是拿一个巨大的乌龟/乌贼神经元，字面意思就是把它从大脑中取出来，平铺在桌子上。当你把一个你可以看见的单一神经元平铺在桌子上时，因为巨型乌贼有
like very, you know, they have a neuron that you can see with the naked eye as I understand it. It's dormant. And then you have to stimulate it with electricity to get it to produce an action potential down its axon. And this is very conveniently consistent with the idea that the stimulus response idea that has really been around in psychology, really since the inception of psychology, right? So psychology as a field was a, was a, field of fundamental philosophy until the mid-19th century when philosophers and neurologists and physiologists started to use the methods available to them from the physiology lab and from
像这样非常……你知道的，据我所知，它们有一个肉眼可见的神经元。它是处于休眠状态的。然后你必须用电流刺激它，让它沿着轴突产生动作电位。这非常方便地与刺激-反应的观点相一致，这种观点在心理学中确实存在，而且自心理学诞生以来就一直存在，对吧？所以心理学作为一个领域，曾是一个基础哲学的领域，直到19世纪中叶，哲学家、神经学家和生理学家开始使用生理学实验室和
patients with lesions to try to search for the physical basis of the psychological categories that were in mental philosophy. So the physical basis of memory, the physical basis of emotion, the physical basis of perception and so on. And the idea was that, you know, the brain is stimulated. The mind is stimulated by something in the world. And then maybe some processing goes on inside and then there's a response. So it's stimulus response jazzed up. This was very consistent with, you know, what happens when you look at an individual neuron lying on a, you know, table.
有病变患者身上可用的方法，试图寻找精神哲学中心理学类别的物理基础。也就是记忆的物理基础、情绪的物理基础、感知的物理基础等等。当时的观点是，你知道，大脑受到了刺激。心灵受到世界中某事物的刺激。然后内部可能会进行一些处理，接着就会产生一个反应。所以这是经过包装的刺激-反应论。这非常符合，你知道的，当你看着一个放在桌子上的单个神经元时发生的情况。
It's dormant and you have to stimulate it in order for it to fire. But that is not how neurons work when they are. actually in situ with other neurons bathed in chemicals and, you know, oxygen and so on. Neurons are constantly talking to each other. Your brain is basically having a conversation with itself throughout your entire life. And that's ongoing. And information from your body and information from the world merely modulate that ongoing activity. And that is the way the brain works. The scientists say, and therapists know this,
它是休眠的，你必须刺激它才能让它放电。但这并不是神经元在实际情况（与浸泡在化学物质和氧气等中的其他神经元在一起）中的工作方式。神经元在不断地互相交谈。你的大脑在你的整个一生中基本上都在与自己对话。而且这种对话一直在进行。来自你身体的信息和来自世界的信息仅仅调节了这种持续的活动。这就是大脑工作的方式。科学家们说，治疗师们也知道这一点，
they use different words, but it's exactly the same idea, that the brain is running a model of the world, an internal model of the world. That's not quite right. The brain is a model, and it's a model of the body as it receives information from the world. So we don't model the world. We model the world. We model the information that arrives to our sensory surfaces, like our retinas and our cochlea and so and so forth, and all the sensory surfaces inside our body. And the brain is receiving this information, and it's attempting to make sense of it so that it knows what to do next to keep itself alive and well. And it's using past experience to make these guesses. So what you see and what you hear and what you smell and what you taste and so on. And what you feel in your body, because you don't really feel
他们用不同的词汇，但这是完全相同的想法——大脑正在运行一个关于世界的模型，一个世界的内部模型。这其实不太对。大脑本身就是一个模型，它是身体接收来自世界的信息时的模型。所以我们不是在模拟世界。我们是在模拟世界。我们模拟的是到达我们感觉表面（如视网膜、耳蜗等等）的信息，以及我们身体内部所有感觉表面的信息。大脑接收这些信息，并试图理解它，以便知道接下来该做什么，从而让自己保持生机和健康。它利用过去的经验来进行这些猜测。所以你所看到的、听到的、闻到的、尝到的等等。以及你在身体里感受到的，因为你并不是真的在
anything in your body. You feel everything in your brain. Everything is felt in your brain. You see in your brain. You don't see in your eyes. You hear in your brain. You don't hear it in your ears. Everything you experience and everything you do is a combination of what's in the world and in your body. Because from your brain's perspective, that's outside the skull, right? So what's in the world, what's in the periphery, and what's in the past that your brain re-implements as the present. Let's turn to your work on emotion, which is also fascinating. And one of the big ideas that you've developed is that the emotions aren't things that happen to us, but there's something that our brain constructs. Explain that.
你的身体里感受到任何东西。你在你的大脑中感受到一切。一切都在你的大脑中被感受到。你在你的大脑中看到。你不是用眼睛看。你在你的大脑中听到。你不是在耳朵里听到。你所经历的一切和你所做的一切都是世界上的事物和身体中的事物的结合。因为从你大脑的角度来看，那是颅骨之外的，对吧？所以，世界上的事物、外周的事物，以及大脑作为现在重新实现的过去的事物。让我们转向你关于情绪的工作，这也是令人着迷的。你发展出的核心观点之一是，情绪不是发生在我们身上的事情，而是我们的大脑构建出来的东西。请解释一下。
Well, yeah. In 25 years old. Yeah, right, exactly. So, You know, if you, what goes along with this idea that we're born with these ancient circuits, right, very deep inside our brain kind of hardwired already there is this idea that emotions happen to you. Something happens in the world like you see a snake and it triggers fear and then fear produces this whole cascade of events. You make a particular facial expression. Your heart rate goes up. Maybe you freeze or you run. And the idea is that this, you know, that this is universal with everybody in the world.
嗯，是的。25岁。对，没错。所以，如果你把这种“我们生来就带有这些远古神经回路，非常深入大脑内部，某种程度上已经硬编码在那里”的观点结合起来，就会有一种“情绪会发生在你身上”的观点。世界上发生了某事，比如你看到了一条蛇，它引发了恐惧，然后恐惧引发了一连串的事件。你做出特定的面部表情。你的心率上升。也许你呆住了或者跑了。这种观点认为，这个，你知道的，这在世界上每个人身上都是普遍的，
everybody who has a nautypical brain who has these circuits which are derived from ancient mammals or were evolved in hunter-gatherer society in Africa or whatever there are different versions of it and I'm painting kind of a
每一个拥有非典型神经大脑的人，他们拥有这些源自远古哺乳动物或在非洲的狩猎采集社会中进化的回路，或者无论哪种版本，都有不同的版本，我在描绘一种
you might want to say it's a straw man sort of a description but you know you can add bells and whistles and nuances but the basic idea is that emotions are universal they have a single set you know anger is has a single set of features, maybe with some variation, but not so much variation that you can't
你可能会说是稻草人式的描述，但是，你知道的，你可以添加花里胡哨的东西和细微差别，但基本的想法是情绪是普遍的，它们有一组单一的（你知道的）愤怒有一组单一的特征，也许有一些变化，但变化不会大到你无法
recognize it in someone's face or in their body or in their body movements or in their voice or whatever. And all I can say is, I know it feels that way. It feels that way to me too, you know, when I get angry, when I'm, you know, when I feel gratitude or any rush of emotion to me feels exactly the same way as it feels to you. But that is not how the brain works. And that is not what the evidence shows. I mean, so the evidence shows really clearly, it couldn't be clearer, frankly, that emotions are not universal. What is universal, however, is that the human brain is constantly constructing experience. It's constantly trying to make sense of the world around and the body, or actually I would say it's trying to make sense of what's going on inside the body
在别人的脸上、身体上、身体动作中或声音中或其他地方认出它来。我能说的是，我知道感觉确实如此。对我来说也是这种感觉，你知道的，当我生气的时候，当我感到感激或者任何情绪的涌动时，对我的感觉和你感受到的完全一样。但大脑并不是这样工作的。证据也不是这样显示的。我的意思是，证据非常清楚地显示，坦率地说，不可能再清楚了，情绪并不是普遍的。然而，普遍的是，人类大脑在不断地构建体验。它一直在试图理解周围的世界和身体，或者实际上我想说的是，它试图理解身体内部正在发生的事情
in relation to what's going on around us outside in the world. And it's doing this using past experience, and it's always doing this. So the way I would say it is kind of like this. The evidence to me suggests very strongly that your brain receives sense data from the world, sights and sounds and smells and so on, and it receives sense data from the body. And so when there's a loud bang or a tug in your chest, your brain receives that information as the outcomes of some set of causes.
与我们外部世界正在发生的事情之间的关系。它利用过去的经验来做到这一点，并且它一直在这样做。所以我的表达方式大概是这样的。在我看来，证据非常有说服力地表明，你的大脑接收来自世界的感官数据（视觉、听觉、嗅觉等），并且它接收来自身体的感官数据。因此，当有巨响或胸口一紧时，你的大脑会将该信息接收为某种原因的结果。
But what caused that loud bang? Is it a car backfiring? Is it somebody slamming a door? Is it a gunshot? What's happening? You know, what caused that tug in your chest? Is it anxiety? Is it that you over ate?
但究竟是什么引起了那声巨响？是汽车回火吗？是有人砰地关上门吗？是枪声吗？发生了什么？你知道的，是什么导致了你胸口的那种紧缩感？是焦虑吗？是你吃多了吗？
You know, too much you have heartburn from like, you know, eating too rich of a meal? Is it the beginning of a heart attack? your brain actually doesn't know. It only receives the outcomes. It has to guess at what the causes are. This is called an inverse problem. You know what the outcome is. You don't know what the cause is. And so your brain has one other source of information available to it. And that is past experience. memory. So it's not like you walk around consciously remembering things in order to perceive the world. Your brain is constantly remembering, meaning it is constantly reassembling bits and pieces of past experience in order to make sense of what's going on in the body in relation to the world so that
你知道的，是不是因为吃了太油腻的餐食而导致胃灼热？是心脏病发作的开始吗？你的大脑其实并不知道。它只接收结果。它必须猜原因是什么。这被称为逆问题。你知道结果是什么。你不知道原因是什么。所以你的大脑还有另一个可用的信息来源。那就是过去的经验。记忆。所以这并不意味着你四处走动时有意识地记住事情来感知世界。你的大脑一直在记忆，这意味着它不断地重新组合过去经验的零星片段，以便理解身体内部与世界的关系，从而
your brain knows what to do next. Because frankly, if a loud bang is a door slamming, you would do something different in a particular situation than, you know, if it was a gun fire, if it was a gunshot. And so what your brain is, you know, if you were to, you know, anthropomorphize a bit, you'd say, you know, what your brain is constantly doing is it's asking the question, what is similar in my past, what is similar to what this sensory array looks like and what caused it and what did I do about it and did it work? Now, in psychology, things that are similar. to one another are a category. So your brain, you could say, is constructing categories. It's a
让你的大脑知道下一步该做什么。因为坦率地说，如果一声巨响是一扇门关上的声音，你在特定情况下所做的事情会与如果是枪声时不同。所以你的大脑是，你知道的，如果你要将它拟人化一点，你会说，你的大脑一直在做的是，它在问这样一个问题：我的过去有什么是相似的，什么类似于这个感觉阵列的外观，是什么引起了它，我对此做了什么，它起作用了吗？现在，在心理学中，彼此相似的事物构成了一个类别。所以你的大脑，你可以说，正在构建类别。它是一个
category construction organ. It's constantly using the past to construct categories to make sense of the present in order for the purposes of guiding action and regulating metabolism. But we also know that a representation of a category is a concept. So you could say also that what the brain is doing is it's doing concept generation, ad hoc concept generation. Your brain is constantly remembering, reassembling past experience as concepts that are tailored to the specific situation that you're in to make sense of what your body means in that particular situation so that it knows what to do next to keep you alive and well. And that's what emotions are. Emotions are just when your brain uses past experiences of emotion to make meaning of the present and guide action.
类别构建器官。它不断地利用过去来构建类别，以理解当下，其目的是指导行动和调节新陈代谢。但我们也知道，对类别的表征就是一个概念。所以你也可以说，大脑正在做的是概念生成，即席概念生成。你的大脑不断地记忆，将过去的经验重新组合成针对你所处的特定情境定制的概念，以理解你的身体在该特定情境中的意义，从而知道下一步该做什么来保持你的生机和健康。这就是情绪。情绪就是你的大脑利用过去的情绪经验来赋予当下意义并指导行动。
If emotion is something that our brain creates, then can we will ourselves to feel emotions differently? I mean, how much control do we actually have over our emotions? Well, I would say that we definitely can, but it's much harder to do than actually sometimes we make it out to be. and every client that every therapist has ever had knows this to be true. It's actually very, very hard to do. And also what it means is that what control looks like doesn't only happen in the moment when a person wants to change how they feel. So one thing I haven't done is made the distinction between affect and emotion.
如果情绪是我们的大脑创造的东西，那么我们能否用意志力来以不同的方式感受情绪呢？我的意思是，我们对自己的情绪究竟有多少控制力？嗯，我会说我们绝对可以，但实际上这比我们有时想象的要难得多。每个治疗师接待过的每一个客户都知道这是真的。这其实非常非常难做到。而且这也意味着，控制所呈现的样子不仅仅发生在一个人想要改变自己感觉的那一刻。所以有一件事我还没有做，那就是区分affect（情感/情绪反应）和emotion（情绪）。
And that's a really important distinction in the science that we do. You know, emotions are easier to change. Affect is not as easy to change in the moment. moment. So let me back up a little bit and explain that distinction and then I will answer your question. Your brain is always controlling your body and your body is always sending sense data back to your brain. And for the most part, we are not aware of all of those sense data to the same degree that we're aware of sights and sounds and smells and things. At least I hope you're not. If you are aware of what's going on inside your body, I feel really bad for you because it means
这在我们开展的科学研究中是一个非常重要的区别。你知道，情绪更容易改变。在当下，情感没那么容易改变。所以我稍微退一步，解释一下这个区别，然后我来回答你的问题。你的大脑总是在控制你的身体，而你的身体总是把感官数据反馈给你的大脑。在大多数情况下，我们并没有意识到所有这些感官数据，其程度就像我们意识到视觉、听觉、嗅觉和其他事物一样。至少我希望你没有。如果你意识到你的身体内部正在发生什么，我真的为你感到难过，因为这意味着
that you've got a whole drama unfolding there. And if you're aware of it, that means that you're probably in significant discomfort and I'm really sorry. But what evolution has done is made available that information to us as affect, as simple feelings. I feel pleasant. I feel worked up.
你体内有一整场戏剧正在上演。如果你意识到了，这意味着你可能处于严重的不适中，我真的很抱歉。但进化所做的是将这些信息作为affect（情感）、作为简单的感觉提供给我们。我感觉很愉快。我感到很亢奋。
I feel calm. I feel comfortable. I feel uncomfortable. So your brain is regulating your body 24-7. Your body is sending information back to your train 24-7, and you feel affect, 24-7, regardless of whether you're emotional or not, you feel affect. Affect is universal.
我感到平静。我感觉舒适。我感到不舒服。所以你的大脑24/7都在调节你的身体。你的身体24/7都在向你的大脑发送信息，而无论你是否有情绪，你24/7都能感受到情感。情感是普遍的。
Now, what affective features are associated with different things is not necessarily universal, always, but affect is universal. The ability, the capacity to have affect is universal, and most likely all mammals and many vertebrates, probably maybe all vertebrates, and maybe even some invertebrates can, also feel affect. That's a, you know, that's an interesting, you know, morass of confusion there. But it's interesting to talk about and think about. But, you know, I would say affect is, is definitely not a human specific ability. And sometimes when we're making meaning of the sensations and the affect that goes with it, sometimes we make episodes of emotion by
现在，什么样的情感特征与不同的事物相关联，不一定总是普遍的，但情感是普遍的。拥有情感的能力是普遍的，最可能的是所有的哺乳动物和许多脊椎动物，可能甚至是所有的脊椎动物，甚至可能是一些无脊椎动物，也能够感受到情感。这是一个，你知道的，一个有趣的混乱泥潭。但讨论和思考它很有趣。不过，你知道，我想说情感绝对不是人类特有的能力。有时，当我们在理解感觉以及随之而来的情感时，有时我们会通过
again, creating categories or concepts on the fly. In fact, there's a convenient term called a conceptual category, which means that the concept, that knowledge is what makes a bunch of things similar to each other in a category. Because a bunch of things can be similar to each other by virtue of their function, not by virtue of what they look like or smell like or sound like or taste like. And many things that we deal with in life are categories of that sort. And infants learn those kinds of categories in the first year of infancy.
再次即兴创造类别或概念来制造情绪片段。事实上，有一个方便的术语叫做“概念类别”（conceptual category），这意味着概念，即知识，使得一堆事物在一个类别中彼此相似。因为许多事物可以通过它们的功能彼此相似，而不是通过它们的外观、气味、声音或味道。我们在生活中处理的许多事情都是这种类别的。婴儿在婴儿期的第一年就学会了这种类别。
They're called abstract categories where the similarity that draws the instances together are not perceptual. They're functional. That is, they serve some kind of function. And this is something I talk about in seven and a half lessons. And so affect is hard to change because you don't have volitional control over your heart and your lungs. You do have volitional control over your breathing.
它们被称为抽象类别，其中将实例吸引在一起的相似性不是知觉上的，而是功能上的。也就是说，它们具有某种功能。这也是我在《七个半堂课》中讨论的内容。所以情感很难改变，因为你对你的心脏和肺没有意志控制力。你对你的呼吸有意志控制力。
And you can try to practice breathing in order to calm your heart and, you know, control your heart and so on and so forth. But you can't stop your blood from flowing. No. And so, and you can't, it's really, most people can't speed their heart up just by thinking about it. And, you know, so affect is actually really hard to change without drugs, like in the instant, you know. And that's really often why people use drugs, both prescription, you know, chemical. and unprescribed chemicals because they're attempting to relieve discomfort or distress, which is affective in nature.
你可以尝试练习呼吸来平静你的心脏，你知道的，控制你的心脏等等。但你无法阻止血液流动。不。所以，而且你不能，大多数人不能仅仅通过思考来加速他们的心跳。你知道的，所以情感实际上很难在不使用药物（比如即时起效的药物）的情况下改变。而这实际上往往就是人们使用药物的原因，包括处方化学药物
But you definitely can change how you make sense of affect and the sensations that give rise to it. But there I would say in the moment, for example, what would James Gross and others call re-appraisal is just you could think of it mechanistically as your brain is recaptu. categorizing a set of the set of sensations is recategorizing what they mean. That is, it's conjuring a different category, a different concept to make sense of those sensations and therefore give rise to a different action. So in the moment, you can do that very deliberately, but sometimes even that is really, really, really, really hard to do. And one way to have more control over your emotions, in addition to just, you know, keeping, making it easier for your brain to regulate your body,
和非处方化学药物，因为他们试图缓解不适或痛苦，而这种不适或痛苦本质上是情感上的。但你绝对可以改变你如何理解情感以及产生情感的感觉。但在这里我想说，在当下，例如，詹姆斯·格罗斯（James Gross）等人所称的“重新评价”（re-appraisal），你可以从机械论的角度将其视为你的大脑正在重新分类。将一组感觉重新分类，即重新分类它们的含义。也就是说，它在变出一个不同的类别、一个不同的概念来理解这些感觉，从而产生不同的行动。所以在当下，你可以非常刻意地做到这一点，但有时甚至连这一点也真的、真的、真的、真的很难做到。除了仅仅……你知道的，让你的大脑更容易调节你的身体之外，掌控你情绪的方法之一还有
which is like get enough sleep, eat healthfully, you know, surround yourself with people who, you know, care about you and who you love and have good relationships with. In addition to those things, you know, you can learn and practice reconceptualizing that is changing the categories that your brain can make easily. So it's kind of like exercise, you know, or like driving. You know, first of all, it is like exercise because it's very effortful to do this. And so it's like an investment in a healthier you. But it is also like driving where at first it's really hard.
比如获得充足的睡眠，健康饮食，你知道的，周围环绕着那些关心你、你爱他们并且与你有良好关系的人。除了这些事情之外，你知道的，你可以学习和练习重新概念化，也就是改变你的大脑可以轻易制造的类别。所以这有点像锻炼，你知道的，或者像开车。首先，它确实像锻炼，因为这样做非常费力。所以这就像是对更健康的自己的投资。但它也像开车，起初真的很难。
But then when you practice it really a lot, you know, it gets easier and pretty automatic. So you can take anxiety and turn it into determination or exhilaration even. You can take anger and turn it into awe. the aspect stays the same, but the meaning is what's changing. And if you practice in advance, you're like seeding your brain to be able to do this much more automatically. So, for example, you know, I'm like skeptical by nature, but there is research to show that gratitude and compassion and awe are very good for your nervous system and therefore for
但当你练习得非常多时，你知道的，它变得更容易，也相当自动化。所以你可以把焦虑变成决心甚至是兴奋。你可以把愤怒变成敬畏。方面保持不变，但意义在改变。如果你提前练习，你就像是在播撒种子，让你的大脑能够更自动地做到这一点。所以，例如，你知道的，我本质上有怀疑精神，但有研究表明，感激、同情和敬畏对你的神经系统非常好，因此对
your mental health. And right down the hall for me is a colleague who studies gratitude and the importance of gratitude. So I'm like, okay, fine, you know, all right, I'll try it. And so I set myself the task of, you know, gratitude I was already on board with, but all was a trickier one. So I thought, all right, I'll try to, you know, cultivate a sense of wonder for five minutes every day where, you know, I'm a spec and therefore my problems are a spec and, you know, let's see if I can do it. And sure enough, you know, it was hard at first, but I did it just like, you know, I learned to, you know, do a plant, hold a plank for a minute or two, whatever. And, um, and eventually it became really easy. And now I can switch in and out of, you know, that particular, um, state. My brain can make
你的心理健康也非常好。就在我办公室走廊的尽头，有一位研究感激之情及其重要性的同事。所以我想，好吧，好吧，你知道的，好吧，我试试。所以我给自己设定了一个任务，你知道的，感激我已经接受了，但敬畏是一个更棘手的问题。所以我想，好吧，我试着每天花五分钟培养一种惊叹感，在那里，你知道的，我是一个微粒，因此我的问题也是一个微粒，你知道的，看看我能不能做到。果不其然，你知道的，起初很难，但就像我学会了做平板支撑一两分钟或其他什么一样，我做到了。而且，最终它变得非常容易。现在我可以随意切换进出那种特定的状态。我的大脑可以做到
it easily when I need it. And, um, and give my nervous system, you know, if you're a spec for a minute, your, your problems are a spec for a minute. And that gives you a break for a minute. And that gives you a break for a minute. And that changes how you breathe and it changes how you comport your body and it changes what you do next. So a lot of the things that we kind of know by different names, we misunderstand mechanistic way in which they occur. Right. So appraisal or reappraisal is a description of something that happens, it's not an explanation of the process that produces it. And by understanding how your brain works, you can generalize that process and start using it in new other ways. So, for example, you can learn other emotion concepts from other cultures that don't exist in our culture,
当需要时可以轻松做到。并且，嗯，让我的神经系统，你知道的，如果你只是微不足道的一会儿，你的问题也只是微不足道的一会儿。这能让你休息一会儿。这能让你休息一会儿。这会改变你的呼吸方式，改变你的身体姿态，并改变你接下来要做的事情。所以很多我们用不同名字称呼的事物，我们对它们发生的机械化方式存在误解。没错。所以评价或重新评价是对所发生事情的描述，它并不是对产生该过程的解释。通过了解你的大脑如何工作，你可以将该过程泛化，并开始以新的其他方式使用它。例如，你可以从我们文化中不存在的其他文化中学习其他的情绪概念，
but that might be really useful for helping you to make sense of your affect and the sensations that give rise to it so that you can broaden the repertoire of actions that you can potentially take. And we know from the wonderful work of George Bonanno that flexibility is the key to resilience in any situation, even a really stressful one. And so that's a way you can control your emotional life, cultivate your emotional life, architect your life, architect your experience in a way that is before the heat of the moment. So what are the big unanswered questions in your field and what are you working on now? Oh my God. Well, I have a lab of 25 full-time people and, you know, a hundred or so undergraduate researchers. So we have many, many questions that we are trying to understand.
但这些概念对于帮助你理解你的情感以及产生情感的感受可能非常有用，这样你就可以拓宽你潜在能够采取的行动剧目。我们从乔治·博纳诺（George Bonanno）的出色研究中得知，在任何情况下，灵活性都是适应力的关键，即使在压力极大的情况下也是如此。所以这是一种你可以控制你的情感生活、培养你的情感生活、构建你的生活、在热烈时刻到来之前构建你的体验的方式。那么你领域中未解的大问题是什么？你现在在研究什么？天哪。我有拥有25名全职员工的实验室，还有大约100名左右的本科研究员。所以我们有非常非常多试图去理解的问题。
But one thing we're trying to understand, for example, is the name for your brain sensing your body is called interoception. And usually interception is studied as your awareness of your physical sensation. Are you aware of your heartbeat? But that's really a very small part of what interception is. Your brain is estimating the state of your body. It's modeling your body, basically. And most of that state estimation is happening outside of your awareness at all completely. You just have no awareness of it. And so that's a question we're really interested in. Not the question of like, are you're aware of your heartbeats, but how well is your brain actually tracking what's happening in your body? Because one cause of depression, for example, could be that your brain has a mistaken
但我们试图理解的一件事是，例如，你的大脑感知身体的名称被称为“机体感觉”（interoception）。通常，机体感觉被研究为你对身体感觉的觉察。你能察觉到你的心跳吗？但这其实只是机体感觉很小的一部分。你的大脑在估计你的身体状态。基本上，它在模拟你的身体。而大部分状态估计完全发生在你的觉察之外。你根本没有对它的觉察。所以这是我们真正感兴趣的问题。不是像你是否察觉到心跳那样的问题，而是你的大脑在多大程度上真正追踪着你体内发生的事情？因为抑郁症的一个原因，例如，可能是你的大脑有一个错误的
model of your body. And there's some disconnect there. So that's one thing that we're really mechanistically trying to work out. Another is, you know, in the way that we understand some things that we think something first and then we act, or we think something first and then we feel something. So we go in and we try to tinker with how people think in order to change how they feel and what they do. But actually, the way the brain works is that your brain prepares your actions first and your experiences derive from that.
身体模型。其中存在一些脱节。所以这是我们正在从机制上努力弄清楚的一件事。另一个是，你知道的，在我们理解某些事情的方式中，我们认为我们先思考然后行动，或者我们先思考然后感受到什么。所以我们介入并试图调整人们的思考方式，以便改变他们的感受和他们的行为。但实际上，大脑的工作方式是，你的大脑首先准备你的行动，而你的体验是由此衍生出来的。
It's not the other way around. And this is also something that I explain in both books, actually. And there's a very strong likelihood that what's happening is not that you think bad things and then you feel bad, more like you feel bad and that leads your brain to think bad things. So it could be that there are problems with the way that your brain is modeling your body or literally problems with your body. For example, maybe your mitochondria are not as effective as they need to be.
情况并非相反。这也是我在两本书中都解释过的事情。而且很有可能发生的情况并不是你思考糟糕的事情然后你感觉糟糕，更像是你感觉糟糕，这导致你的大脑去思考糟糕的事情。因此，可能存在的问题是你的大脑模拟身体的方式有问题，或者字面意义上你的身体有问题。例如，也许你的线粒体不如它们需要的那般高效。
And that could be a source of depression. That could be a source of, you know, this disconnect. Your brain is attempting to model your body. Your body's not functioning well in this really, you know, subtle way that you would not be aware of, but maybe you'd just be aware of feeling bad, and that that is actually what's driving those negative thoughts, not the other way around. To me, this seems, first of all, very plausible from a neuroscience standpoint. And what it means is that when we go in and we get people to change how they're thinking in order to change how they feel, what we're doing is actually just breaking a cycle.
这可能是抑郁症的根源。这可能是，你知道的，这种脱节的根源。你的大脑正试图模拟你的身体。你的身体在以这种你不会察觉到的微妙方式运作得不好，但也许你只会察觉到感觉糟糕，而这实际上才是驱动那些负面想法的原因，而不是相反。对我来说，从神经科学的角度来看，这首先是非常合理的。这意味着，当我们介入并让人改变他们的思考方式以改变他们的感受时，我们实际上只是在打破一个循环。
We're not changing the cause of the problem. We're just interrupting an ongoing cycle. And again, I would say there are real lessons there about things that you might want to do differently if this is actually. It's not that what we're doing is bad. It's just that there might be additional things that we might want to think about doing
我们没有改变问题的根源。我们只是打断了一个正在进行的循环。再说一次，我会说这里有一些真正的教训，关于如果你实际这么做，你可能想要做些不同的事情。这并不是说我们正在做的事情不好。只是可能还有额外的事情是我们想要考虑去做的
for treating mental illness. Well, it just sounds amazing the work that you're doing. I really appreciate you're taking the time to speak with me today. And I highly recommend, I mean, maybe I shouldn't say this, but I think your new book is very accessible and a great read. So I appreciate the time that you've taken. Thank you. Thank you. Thanks, thanks very much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeckiology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word at APA.org.
用于治疗精神疾病。嗯，你所做的工作听起来太棒了。非常感谢你今天花时间跟我交谈。我强烈推荐，我的意思是，也许我不该这么说，但我认为你的新书非常平易近人，是一本极好的读物。所以我很感激你抽出的时间。谢谢。谢谢。非常感谢。你可以在 www.combeckiology.org 或通过 Apple、Stitcher 以及你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学之声》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，在 APA.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学之声》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。